le MacBook Air 15 pouces de 2023 est un
des meilleurs ordinateurs j'ai pu tester
je vais donc vous donner aujourd'hui 10
raisons de venir le choisir mais à la
fin également six raisons de peut-être
passer votre chemin première raison
c'est la première fois qu'on va arriver
un écran de 15 pouces sur un MacBook Air
avant on avait des écrans 13 pouces ça
vient augmenter vraiment la taille ça
met littéralement ce Mac dans une
nouvelle catégorie on aura donc beaucoup
plus de confort de visionnage plus
pratique pour venir regarder du contenu
film série l'utiliser également pour
travailler la productivité bref cet
écran est beaucoup plus grand et ça
j'adore en plus de ça la dalle est
extrêmement bien calibrée et rien que
pour ça c'est un très grand bravo Apple
la deuxième raison c'est la puce que
vous avez à l'intérieur la puce Apple
silicone m2 qui est juste une petite
tuerie elle apporte beaucoup de
performances il est extrêmement rapide à
l'ouverture et à la fermeture des
applications pas de latence pas de lac
ça marche il est surtout 12 fois plus
rapide qu'un MacBook Air de la
génération Intel autant vous dire que là
ça n'a strictement plus rien à voir le
troisième point c'est le regain
d'autonomie comme vous avez cette puce
N2 qui est beaucoup moins énergivore
vous allez aller vachement plus loin
jusqu'à 18h d'utilisation alors
peut-être pas 18h réellement stric mais
pour autant vous allez pouvoir aller
super loin en utilisation de votre
MacBook Air le quatrième point c'est
qu'il est extrêmement silencieux au
niveau de sa fabrication vous avez
absolument aucun ventilateur là où sur
un MacBook Pro il va falloir venir
ventiler pour sortir la chaleur
forcément il va venir tartiner davantage
sur un MacBook Air vous avez aucun
ventilateur nulle part comme c'est pas
une machine qui est faite pour être
utilisé de manière intensive pas trop de
risques de venir la faire trop chauffer
donc pas besoin de ventilateur le
cinquième point c'est le design le mec
booker est un ordinateur extrêmement fin
qui passera parfaitement bien dans
n'importe quel sac ça c'est quand même
super les finitions sont irréprochables
à l'extérieur à l'intérieur c'est
vraiment une machine que j'adore en plus
de ça vous avez chaud entre 4 coloris
minuit lumière stellaire gris sidéral et
argent vous avez plus qu'à faire votre
choix le sixième point c'est son boîtier
en aluminium 100% recyclé Apple va
toujours plus loin dans
l'éco-responsabilité et ça on aime que
serait un axe en MacOS qui est une des
meilleures expériences qu'on peut
trouver sur un ordinateur et qui surtout
une partie centrale de l'écosystème
d'Apple vous envoyez recevez des
fichiers très facilement grâce à AirDrop
vous synchronisez tout dans le Cloud
avec iCloud il y a également l'assistant
de migration qui très simple pour venir
configurer son mac bref c'est complet ça
marche bien c'est très simple et c'est
extrêmement efficace le huitième point
c'est l'audio l'expérience audio sur les
Mac aujourd'hui et absolument incroyable
déjà avec le MacBook Pro 16 pouces la
dernière version vinted était juste top
au niveau du son les MacBook Pro sont
toujours extraordinaires et ce MacBook
Air également très bon alors on n'ira
pas aussi loin que ce qu'on va voir avec
un macbook pro mais pour autant en terme
d'immersion c'est juste génial et vous
avez en plus une prise en charge de
l'audiospatiale avec Dolby Atmos et
croyez-moi c'est pas uniquement une
fiche technique lorsque vous écoutez du
son qui sort votre MacBook Air c'est
vraiment bluffant j'adore le clavier de
smack booker super agréable à venir
utiliser retour de touche qui est
magnifique vous avez en plus touch Idy
pour venir le déverrouiller très
facilement sans oublier un énorme tripad
c'est clair simple lisible efficace tout
simplement et que serait-ce MacBook Air
sans maxife vous prenez vous le mettez
en face il est monté vous avez la LED
pour savoir s'il est en train de charger
et si quelqu'un par inadvertance vient
tirer dessus et bien ça va pas faire
tomber votre Mac ça l'arrache pas c'est
pratique c'est vachement bien autre
point positif ça vient pas occupé à des
deux ports usb-c comme ça vous pourrez
les utiliser pour faire tout ce que vous
voulez et un truc qui est bien vu vous
avez deux ports USB C sur votre blog de
charge comme ça je peux dire brancher
ici mon MacBook Air et pourquoi pas
au-dessus mon iPhone c'est pratique bon
tout ça c'est bien beau maintenant il y
a quand même quelques points négatifs
sur ce MacBook Air qui font que des fois
bon le premier c'est que bien que vous
ayez des ports usb-c sur la partie
gauche vous n'avez absolument rien sur
la partie droite alors rien presque vous
avez quand même une prise jack c'est pas
mal mais pas assez si je viens brancher
un disque dur externe un moniteur et que
sais-je encore va falloir faire des
choix je suis toujours pas hyper fan de
l'encoche qu'on vient retrouver ici
alors même si c'est vachement bien
intégré d'un point de vue logiciel à
savoir que si je mets une vidéo en plein
écran et bien ne va pas venir empiéter
sur mon encoche pour autant ça empêchera
d'étendre une vidéo jusqu'au plus haut
de mon écran et des fois ça peut être un
peu dommage d'autant plus qu'ici vous
avez une encoche mais pas de facidy ça
c'est quand même bizarre le troisième
point c'est le tarif vous débutez quand
même à presque 1600 euros avec une
version de stockage en 256 et si vous
voulez monter un peu plus en 512 vous
êtes à 1829 euros tout en sachant que 8
Go de RAM c'est pas assez pour prendre
au moins 16 g et ce que j'aimerais quand
même recommander ici c'est partir sur
312 sont un Téra un terrain c'est pas
mal il a l'addition monte tout de suite
2289 euros ça reste quand même une somme
autre point qui me fait rien c'est
l'indice de réparabilité 6,4 sur 10 ça
veut dire que votre ordinateur est pas
très simple à réparer donc s'il est une
panne bon alors après vous avez une
garantie 2 ans garantie il y a pas de
problème mais au bout des deux ans 6,4
sur 10 pour détails mais qui a son
importance vous avez un écran LCD pas un
écran OLED alors dans l'absolu les
vachement bien calibré c'est un très bel
écran mais quand on sait que sur un
écran OLED un pixel noir et d'un pixel
éteint on se dit que sur le Dark mode le
thème sombre on aurait encore plus
d'autonomie alors 18h vous me direz sur
le papier c'est quand même plutôt pas
mal même si c'est que 15 même si c'est
que 13 mais pour autant pour gagner un
peu plus et avoir des Noirs un peu plus
profonds et des contrastes un peu
meilleur et puis le dernier point pour
voir qu'on est sur des dernières
machines ici il y a pas de wifi 6e wifi
6 uniquement ce qui est déjà bien mais
le festif c'est quand même un peu mieux
malgré tout ça le MacBook Air 15 de 2023
est juste top d'ailleurs si vous hésitez
encore entre un Mac et un PC allez voir
ma vidéo sur le dernier Galaxy book 3
ultra vous allez voir que c'est une
vraie petite bombe et peut-être que
votre cœur ira plutôt chez Samsung ou
plutôt chez Apple allez savoir il y a du
bon des deux côtés en tout cas